حرب المياه بين ايران وافغانستان اشتعلت
اخيرا هي ليست جديده والنزاع مستمر عليها
منذ عقود المنطقه الواقعه جنوب الحدود
الافغانيه الايرانيه هي من اكثر المناطق
القاحله والفقيره في البلدين يعتمد سكانها
اعتمادا كبيرا على مياه نهرها المند رغم
انها موطن لعشره انهار مختلفه الا ان
الجغرافيا في افغانستان تتسبب في تدفق
معظم مياه انهارها الرئيسيه الى جيرانها
ما يؤثر على استفاده الافغان بمياه
الصادره من داخل حدودها ويتسبب في صراعنا
على المياه مع دول الجوار والاسيه ما
ايران نهر هل من نقطه الخلاف بين البلدين
ينبع من جبال هندوكش شمال شرقيه افغانستان
ليمتد على مسافه تتخطى الف150 كيلومترا
ويصب في بحيره هامون جنوب شرقي ايران
هامون هي اراد رطبه عابره للح على الحدود
الايرانيه الافغانيه وتتكون من ثلاث
بحيرات هامون هلموند وهي بالكامل في ايران
وهمون صباري على الحدود واهمون بوزاك وهي
تقريبا تقع في افغانستان بشكل كامل ترتبط
والبحيرات الثلاثه بمياه نهرها الموند
وتتغذى عليه كما ان حوض سيستان الذي يوفر
المياه لولايتي السيستان وبلوشستان في
ايران يعتمد على الفيضانات الدائمه لملء
بحيراته الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
طهران وعلى لساني وزير خارجيتها اتهمت
كابول باستخدام نهر هلموند كاداه سياسيه
خاصه ان 95% من المياه تتدفق داخل الاراضي
الافغانيه
نظريا صحت فلم تكن طالبا اول مستخدميها في
افغانستان في الماضي اطلق الرئيس الافغاني
السابق اشرف غني سياسه المياه مقابل
اللجوء موضحا في تصريح له انه اذا لم
يساعد احد افغانستان في ملف اللاجئين لن
تتعاون كابل مع جيرانها في ملف المياه
هي معاهده كل الافغاني مع ايران لكن
مشكلتنا لم تكن في المعاهده نفسها بل في
طريقه تطبيقها اما من بعد اليوم فان مفتاح
هيلمنت بيد الافغان وينفذون ما اتفقوا
عليهما ايران اما ما هو اكثر من المتفق
عليه سيكون بالتفاوض اعطونا النفط ونعطيكم
الماء او ادفعوا مقابل المياه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات